so rock band blitz was our way to do
something a little bit new with the
world of rock band the format of rhythm
multi production yeah we wanted to step
into the downloadable space uh-huh we
wanted to appeal to those people that
maybe haven't played rock band in a
while say hey guys we're still here try
this out but it's it's an xbla PSN it's
an arcade type game yeah but I gave us a
chance to get a little goofy with rock
but yeah we haven't done before we've
got power ups things exploding all over
the place in a great arcade over-the-top
explosive power up driven multitrack
really fun single-player experience you
compete with all your friends
asynchronously online it's a broad game
so the nice thing about rock band
libraries you can customize the game to
what you want it to be yeah so if you
don't like say the all-american rejects
Oh which a lot of people do what it's
worth or blink 182 which a lot of people
do you you can get your classic rock
metal on you get your iron maiden on
it's really competitive in a way that
other games aren't and again that's like
the Arkady thing that I think will
appeal to that that xbla PSN crowd if
you still have instruments rock band
blitz actually works all the songs
working rock band 3 so you can play all
those songs with instruments if you want
but it's a instruments are a little
gauche I think it's time to get back to
controllers no way instruments are the
new instruments my favorite thing is not
having to set stuff up yeah cuz I
actually love rock band I love the
instruments but sometimes I don't want
to lug things out when I play other
games i'm off to like set things up I've
like pull stuff out of my closet
basically you're not putting your
instruments away forever in a way if
you're an instrument person like chris
kohler you can play all of the songs of
rock band blitz instantly in rock band 3
ya know most of us as if as if you
didn't even buy rock band blitz if you
so desire you can forget the game even
exist yeah and use it as a track pack
let me know I wouldn't recommend that no
let me put you on something hey Eric
yeah I love the songs we've announced
for rock band blitz ya know what hate
the game oh really should i buy it yes
should still buy it yeah why cuz it's a
really affordable track pack it's a
great deal it's a good deal the greatest
deal
you